[Music]
in apigee x networking and routing
configurations are two of the key
prerequisites for api proxy deployment
in the previous video you learned about
the apigex networking architecture and
how to verify the networking
configuration of an apigex organization
in this video you will learn about the
routing data model how it is applied in
apigex instances and how to verify the
routing configuration in an apigee x
organization
are you wondering what is the routing
data model in apigee x
it's a collection of entities and
configurations that ensures that api
requests are routed to the right api
proxy
to route the api request to the correct
api proxy you need to create apigee
instances for provisioning runtime
components in apigee x organizations
an organization can have one or more
instances based on your subscription
entitlements of the organization
and the regional availability
requirements of your api proxies
next attach the environments to the
apigee instances
apigee creates and dedicates runtime
pods for each environment
when the apigee runtime is ready api
developers can create api proxy
divisions and deploy them to
environments
each api proxy revision will have a base
path used to route api requests to the
proxy revision
combine the environments into
environment groups and define the host
names of the api proxy endpoints
finally the host names base parts and
apigee runtime port configuration will
be used to configure the routing
definition of api proxies in the ingress
gateways to illustrate how the routing
data model is used we'll first look at a
single region deployment here the
routing data model will be configured in
the increased gateways in the aperture
instance a global load balancer will
then be configured for routing api
requests to the ingress gateways via a
manage instance group omig
once the api requests are received by
the ingress gateway it will use the host
name configured in the environment group
the base path configured in the ebay
proxy and the environment configuration
for dispatching the request to the
apigee runtime pods for the relevant
environment
in contrast multi-region deployments
will have multiple migs added to the
same backend or separate backends of the
global load balancer
if multiple migs are added to separate
backends host and path rules can be used
for routing api requests to the relevant
apigee x instances based on host names
and parts
before if a request will fail with http
404 not found errors if the api proxy is
not deployed or if the base path is not
found
more importantly http 503 service
unavailable errors will be raised if the
api proxy is deployed to an environment
that is not attached to the instance
all right we are all set
let's switch to the apigee ui and verify
the routing configuration of an api
proxy in a sample apigee x organization
first we'll verify the list of apg
instances and their environment
attachments sign into the apigee ui
navigate to admin environments page and
note the environments associated with
this organization
go to admin instances page and verify
that the environments attached to all of
the instances are correct
in this organization environment dev is
only attached to one instance which is
valid
note you can attach or de-attach
environments of any instance if required
in the admin environments groups page
note the host names configured for the
environments
in this organization the hostname is
defined as dev.example.com
for the dev environment through the dev
dash example environment group
similarly for the test environment the
host name is test.example.com
defined through the test dash example
environment group
we will now verify the ebay proxy
configuration
the revision number one of the sample
proxy hello world is deployed to the dev
environment
the best part of this proxy is
hello-world
great the verification is completed
with this configuration we should be
able to access the ebay proxy hello
world with the host name dev example
dev.example.com and basepath hello wool
through the load balancer
let's try it out
make an api request using the curl
command by mapping the domain name to
the load balancer ip address
congratulations the epa request
completed successfully with the 200
response
thanks for watching
[Music]